all right daddy
yes daddy where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
i was born and raised in new york
and then they moved me to florida
when i was about 11.
and tell me about your family
i love my family the greatest thing
a um
very uh
loving caring
but you know
it's a good it's a good family but it's
got problems like everything in life
like me
i got some problems
of my own but not blame my family or
judge them
for that because i love them how would
you describe your childhood in general
as best they could get me
as best as they could give me a lot of
fun
a lot of memories
good and the bad and i did the good and
the bad but we we had
we had a lot of fun
fishing swimming the boats
you know birthdays friends sports
team you had siblings
four
of us three siblings yeah and uh what
kind of kid were you in high school
oh i struggled to be average and really
shy
really passive it take a lot for me to
talk
i would not be the first one to start
the conversation and stay by myself
you're shy
shy passive
[Music]
and struggle like with grades
you know i struggled to be a c did you
finish high school
yes good for you knows park
and then after after high school where'd
you go
nursing work
i love helping people
you know
do the best you can
did you uh
get involved in drugs or alcohol yes
i still drinking
a big problem with the drink and the
drug and
i i had my fair share
you know
and the strangulation the thing that's
strangulating the thing that's
smothering the thing
you just can't get away and you try it's
like quitting cigarettes and you pick
them right back up
but you try with that alcohol
but the drugs i i i i just i i did it
i did
my problem alcohol how did you start
i i just was a late starter i say like
like most of them
say some other age but me
you know it's the cigarettes
like 15 one here one there i don't call
that smoke and i call it curious trying
even 14
but but other than that the drinking
young
i see i see it because it's always
around me the barbecue the fourth of
july
uh to clean in the house at home
go over to the beach with the family you
know beach oh and you see it you see you
see and you try it
you know first oh you cough like with a
cigarette
oh you
you you puke it up or something young
probably
12
13. i'm drinking i'm not trying it i'm
drinking
you get it have it however you get it
you're not old enough but but it's
around you
you know were there drinkers in your
family
well well well all of them
is
hereditary
it's not
learned it might be learned but it's
hereditary i think it's in your genes
your dna you pass it down
genetically it's it's it's in you
you know like you got your mom's eyes
you got your dad's feet or something
like that we talk about it but yes
my my my family big
my my dad's
one of seven more he got eight he's one
of eight not none of them's daughters
their uncles
no female
no sister my mom's one of
eight and she have one sister i have one
aunt
and all them uncles
and my mom's side every one of them
everyone one of them takes his own life
he commits suicide
about the alcohol and stuff
his life and stuff
sorry
i don't want to cry
did your mom or dad have a problem with
alcohol
my dad don't
my mom don't she do it sociably she the
only one
with no drinking and no drugging
she take care of all of them her
siblings
because she updated older ones
she just got just two of them older than
her
the rest of them younger than her
so you you started young
yeah has alcohol been in your life you
still is today i'm 54 years old
and do you have children
i have two children
i love them very much did you raise them
mostly
mostly i had help and i had some
separating
from them
and then for me
when i tried to make it a better life
and
that's the connection with west virginia
sorry
thank you how old are your children now
i have two daughters
and the oldest one
gonna be 33
and the younger one gonna be
31.
and i have five grandbabies
three grandsons
and two granddaughters
between both my children
and you were how involved in their in
their
their lives as young people yes
how involved were you very well
too overpowering probably two old
parents like mother hubbard
mother hand hover over her
but we have a little separating too
with the kids with the problems with
marriage
with drinking and drugging
and tell me about your drinking how how
how much do you drink
now excuse me
i try not to drink because i i should
not with my medicine and my my health
and i don't want to
i want to try to not
but i drink
maybe i can go maybe just maybe just one
day
but it's awfully hard
because you go through stuff you know
you get sick and everything you can't
eat and you can't sleep and you can't
it's it's horrible
you don't want it but you need it
because you you'll be sick
you'll be puking if you feel you feel
like
you're not yourself
you can't you can't make it through if
you don't go and get it
did you black out sometime
i have i i don't try and do that no more
but but i have is
you know where you are you know what
happened you can't remember nothing
for days for days and you see somebody
and saying you remember that
even
you remember some of it but some of it
you can't believe what what they're
saying
because you don't remember that
when you're doing the blackout
i don't i don't drink the lick no more
when i do just just a little
like a capful and not not the
shot glass
when i drink the lick i pour it like in
the cap i like a water bottle cap or a
gatorade cap it's just a couple caps
that that's blacking out
it's dangerous
how much how much did you drink during
your peak when you were how much do i
drink i'm sorry when you're at your
at your worst oh
every single day how much a case a day
plus plus a shot maybe some days
no case
just it's just a drink a whole bottle
and just chug it down would chase it
with some water
have it on the rocks
yeah you have the bottle and you have it
on on the rocks jack daniels jim beam
whatever
you like some some people like divide
because some people like the gin some
people like
some people like whatever's not going to
make them sick
whatever's is going to make them to take
the pain away
what do you think
is there some pain in your life there's
a lot of pain in my life
emotionally emotionally and physically
and
you know it's just not my pain but
who i am
how i raise them and how i'm taught who
i am myself
and try and help somebody be the nurse
and be the friend and be the sister
and meet a mom and
you try and do it all you know you raise
you raise you know you say you take care
of all the stuff
and you put yourself
when it's all done
then you you worry about yourself
but i learned
when i like 41 years old from a very
good friend of mine
it's easy he said
he happened to be
a male
and i meet him at work
and he say daddy i want you to think
about this
if yourself isn't okay
nothing else can be okay
i never heard
in my ears before i was raised to do
the laundry the house the food the
groceries the bills the kids the fun
the bank the errands
you know then you know do you do
everything you need to do and then you
do you
was there anything in your childhood
that you're
trying to not look at
or makes it difficult to look at it's
still very difficult at 54 it takes a
long time for me to talk
i still can't get it all out
because this too painful is buried too
deep
was there abuse in your childhood i feel
i feel some things happen
that
i cannot
forgive
and
they
they say if you don't forgive
you're gonna hold yourself back
but
i feel they've done the best they could
everybody
and some of them maybe they didn't do
their best they've done the wrong thing
but i don't blame or judge
you you have to take
a responsibility
when you're an adult
and do the best you can
for somebody else
won't
have to go through that
you may you may help them to take a dip
take a different way
make a different choice or
do something sooner
and not let it get
so deep
that they maybe can't get it out
um
[Music]
have you been in love before
yes
it's a beautiful thing
but it's painful too sometimes
it's life
i've been married
a family
a good childhood a good mom good dad
my siblings
my grandparents
my
my love from
to help people
first respond as they
nurses and doctors and paramedics
firemen
police officers there's a lot of love
in this world there's very good people
in this world still
yeah you have to be a good person
you don't have to be perfect
be happy have good intention you have to
have a good heart you have to you have
to have some somebody to
just
you can teach them you can show them you
can have fun with them they they can
learn from you they may help somebody
have a better life
and less pain
more love
more fun
more smiles
you feel like what you went through is
in your childhood
kind of makes it difficult for you to
accept
better things in your life
now as an adult i think so
because i think some some of the things
from my childhood i accept that they
cannot get any greater than they were
and i would not want to change them for
the world
it makes me who i am and i'm proud of
those things
even some of the painful things that
made me who i am made me a stronger
person
it made me through this through the
woods literally literally the woods the
trees crashing down around me of the
water the water to your knees
and the trees crashing down you only got
you you're in the street you homelessly
you you need a drink this is nine
o'clock at night you're by yourself
you don't know if this is electric and
the wire you're gonna die you need to oh
you can't panic you know you know you
know first respond there's no pad but
you're disoriented
you're not right you're getting
i know i get out this way i don't i know
i don't know i sleep here i can do it
with my eyes closed uh
you know something happened just that
natural natural
mother nature the trees is crashing down
it's
flooding because you're a little bit
lower you know
it's just
you living out there on the streets like
that but it made me who i am it made me
stronger person
and i would not give up my family my
childhood my pain my
anything my my my work
my my personality my heart
my love for people
and for life itself i would not change
it for one thing
sometimes i wish i
i may didn't make some choices
but you live and you grow and you learn
and you make mistakes nobody perfect
and i don't think i want to be perfect
so i i don't know what it is to be
perfect it's kind of scary feeling when
you don't know what it is
when you you embrace it it's this change
it's good you embrace it you learn you
go through life
and he'd be okay
you find that you sometimes maybe you
might self-sabotage
yeah i think it is self-destructive i
think it is he
you uh
for some reason it feel like
like you
you beat yourself up for some reason
like
like shoulda coulda woulda
if i only just didn't do that
if i only could have did that but but i
couldn't
sometimes
i feel like that
but but
you do best you can
you cannot
you reach out
you can try and find the right people
right places
right
so you can
maybe
help somebody else to understand what
it's like and that they're not alone
and that they can reach out and they can
talk to somebody and they can
you find helping people is something
that you
i love to on accident
i don't even have to mean to do it set
out to do it
i'm gonna wake up today it's in your
nature
it's just who i am
i
call it
his life
is happy
it's a warm lovely feeling
you can make somebody you you can maybe
save their life
just by saying hi
or just by
acknowledging them
you never never know
what what you can do or what you might
have done
it just is who i am
daddy what brought you to west virginia
the connection with west virginia is is
the man i married the father of my
children
i meet him in florida
we born and raised here
and he have
in huntington
over in huntington that's the connection
no
in florida i meet him he run away from
his mom
and he have some issues too i don't want
to talk about him but i'll answer you
he run away from his mom
and he go with his dad who's military
their marriage didn't make it either
and that's how i meet him in florida
and the separating i was talking about a
little bit from my children
was due to
separating
and gonna divorce my husband
and trusting in his family and trying
trying to make a change trying to do the
right thing
for my children for me in a different
life
maybe i make a mistake
and i get took anybody out of the job
when i talk about the little separating
from the children
that that's the connection
with westminster
my oldest daughter
earned a four-year fully paid
scholarship
to marshall
and she made it like two years
magna [ __ ] laude
and she meets somebody and she fall in
love like people do
and they move
from out of the college
and i want to be closer to my
firstborn grandchild
and i know i don't want to be in florida
i'd have 30-something years and i've
seen it and done it all
i i want to be close
to my
my daughter and my firstborn
grandchild
that's the connection with west virginia
then i come here and this is home now to
me it's a beautiful place
we're very beautiful people
very different but but different isn't
bad
and very good people
what do you worry about now what are you
afraid of at this point in your life
yeah i don't have enough time
because if you have anything
that you want to spend spend time
not money
i prayed
that life is too short
and enough people have not had it sweet
enough
because they haven't took the time
or they
just ran out of time
yeah you
can't get it back
you can't you can't be in the past
because you're gonna miss the future
before you know
it's over in the blink of an eye it can
be just like that so very different so
very from what you know
or just completely gone
do you have regrets in your life
very few
very few
i i don't really think i have many
regrets
some things i'm not so proud of
but it made me who i am
it made me maybe help somebody else
inspire them to
want to be helpful want to be nice and
want to be happy
somebody else can be happy too
daddy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson
if i had to say it right now
without thinking about
don't don't be mean
don't assume that you know
don't assume that you can't change your
mind
don't think that that you can't make a
difference
for yourself
or for someone else
because you can
it's not that hard
it's a lot harder
if you don't take the time
to be who you are
but accept that
it don't have to be regret
it can just be something very important
that it would change the whole
picture the whole outcome
it is maybe the thing that you really
wanted most
all right
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you thank you
you're welcome
you